[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bienvenue dans ces idées qui gouvernent
le monde Freud face au malaise des
civilisations Freud naquit au mi-temps
du 19e siècle à freibberg et il
s'éteignit le 23 septembre 1939 à
Londres après un exil forcé de Vienne le
4 juin 1938 pour échapper à la barbarie
nazie homme des Lumières il est le
fondateur de la psychanalyse une
nouvelle science émanant de la vie d'âme
de ses contemporains au travers de leur
viit temporelle et intemporelle on a
souvent réduit la psychanalyse à la
science des rêves ce qu'elle est mais le
décryptage freudien s'étend jusqu'au
malaise des civilisations en abordant
les besoins aussi divers que la
sexualité la religion les relations
sociales et familiales et des questions
politiques notamment la guerre ou le
nationalisme le savant viennois
s'interrogea je le cite pour pourquoi
les individus peuple se méprisent--ils
se haentil les uns les autres comme si
dès lors qu'on réunit une multitude
toutes les acquisitions morales
s'effacai pour ne laisser place qu'au
traumatisme et au pulsion cette énigme
non résolue va être l'objet de notre
débat nous allons chercher à comprendre
en nous adossant à l'œuvre de Freud les
raisons qui poussent les hommes et les
femmes à sent etué dans une pulsion
d'agression ininterrompu et les
civilisations à
s'entredéchirer dans cette
conflictualité sans fin du monde pour en
parler je vous présente mes invités
Jean-Pierre Legoff vous êtes philosophe
sociologue et esséiste Gérard Miller
vous êtes psychanalyste et esséiste
Juliette Méadel vous êtes ancienne
ministre haut fonctionnaire Jean-Louis
Chassin vous êtes psychiatre et
psychanalyste pierre de sénarclins vous
êtes politologue professeur émérite de
l'Université de
[Musique]
Lausanne alors est-ce que cette
prévision pessimiste de Freud sur la
domination exterminatrice des forces de
la nature extraite de son ouvrage
Malaise dans la civilisation ou selon la
traduction malaise dans la culture vous
paraît-elle d'actualité Jean-Pierre
legof ah oui elle me paraît totalement
d'actualité je dirais surtout après une
période assez angélique c'estàdire si on
remonte un peu dans la sur un
demi-siècle on va dire après la Seconde
Guerre mondiale il y avait encore les
souvenirs de la Choa de la Seconde
Guerre mondiale mais très vite é apperit
un autre type de société qu'on appelait
la société de consommation et de loisirs
avec une forme d'édonis à ces nouvelles
mais si on va beaucoup plus loin encore
il y a eu la chute du mur de Berlin et
la façon dont la construction européenne
a été lancée et je pense qu'il y a eu
une espèce d'angélce l'utopie d'une
espèce de fin de l'histoire et du
tragique é inhérant à l'histoire qui
s'est développé à ce moment-là avec
l'idée que finalement les hommes
pouvaient se s'entendre sans qu'il y ait
une part d'agressivité avec l'idée même
de la fin des guerres c'est-à-dire le
doux commerce c'est-à-dire quand même le
libéralisme le néolibéralisme plus les
droits de l'homme et c'était un peu la
fin de l'histoire à partir de on pensait
que l'ensemble du monde allit vers ce
mouvement il s'est trouvé que ça été
assez vite démenti il y a eu la guerre
du Kosovo de la Serbie en Europe qui est
revenu directement qui a remontré le le
tragique il y a eu aussi moi je mettrais
le covid d'une certaine façon par
rapport à cette espèce d'uphorie tout
d'un coup on retrouve le tragique et la
mort possible et alors aujourd'hui vous
avez les guerres les guerres en Europe
avec Poutine plus les risques de guerre
donc tout ça c'est un peu effondré le
terrorisme islamiste avec quelque chose
qui m'a beaucoup frappé c'est la
difficulté à assumer le fait qu'il peut
y avoir en face de nous des ennemis qui
veulent nous détruire je vais pas
reprendre Julien Freud mais que vous le
vouliez ou non vous avez des ennemis et
vous vous avez beau dire j'en veux pas
ils viennent vous chercher dans le
jardin d'une certaine façon et ça il
quand je voyais par exemple les
manifestations contre les attentats de
Charlie Hebdo j'avais été frappé par des
espèces de nouveaux rituels de deuil
avec des bougies des ballons et un
certain type de champ qu'on mettait
souvent en avant qui des John Lennon
imagine un monde enfin pacifié c'était
pas l'ennemi connaîtra le prix du sang
et des larmes si je reprends le champ
des partisans c'était l'inverse et il y
a une difficulté aujourd'hui on
progresse à affronter cette réalité
c'està-dire une part d'agressivité qui
est indestructible au sein de l'être
humain pour reprendre la formule ça
c'est très difficile mais je pense que
si vous regardez le cheminement on y
arrive mais avec chaque avec à chaque
fois des points de fuite alors cette
vérité freudienne intemporelle vous la
partagez Gérard Miller alors Malaise
dans la civilisation malaise dans la
culture c'est 1929 1929 c'est la crise
économique c'est la montée de plus en
plus nette au pouvoir des nazis on peut
se dire ah on comprend pourquoi tout
particulièrement à ce moment-là Freud
était pessimiste et pourquoi d'ailleurs
il dit moi-même qui qui est plus de 70
ans c'est à mes petits- enfants que je
pense parce que pour moi évidemment tout
est déjà
foutu il faut bien dire que
contrairement à ce qu'on a évoqué moi je
n'ai jamais cru et pas seulement parce
que j'étais freien à la fin de
l'histoire qui a été un petit moment
très court dans l'idéologie venu des
États-Unis parce que ma génération c'est
la génération qui a connu la guerre du
Vietnam et qui a connu ensuite toute une
série de catastrophes en tout genre
simplement même la pauvreté et la misère
en France m'ont permis de croire que de
toute façon en effet le pessimisme
fredien était intemporel mais je pense
que ce qu'on va essayer d'expliquer
justement c'est c'est pourquoi d'une
certaine façon quand on est freudien on
ne peut malheureusement qu'être
pessimiste alors j'ur de dire sur le
long terme au court terme essayons
d'être heureux élever nos enfants avec
bonheur mais sur le long terme quand on
est freredien on ne peut-être que
pessimiste oui Juliette
madel je je serais moins pessimiste que
vous non pas sur l'avenir mais sur le
passé parce qu'au fond si il y a quelque
chose que nous nous ont appris ces 25
dernières années c'est que on avait
justement cherché à domestiquer ces
pulsions d'agressivité je suis toujours
assez frappé quand on dit ah c'était
mieux avant c'était beaucoup plus apaisé
par exemple pour ne parler que de ça de
la violence dans le débat politique on
dit toujours ah mais avant c'était
beaucoup plus apaisé ce qui est tout à
fait faux parce qu'en réalité on voit
bien qu'à la fin du 19e siècle les
caricatures étaient d'une agressivité
inouie et que au fond cette violence
qu'on déplore aujourd'hui était bien
pire dans la société la culture n'a pas
corrigé chose ça veut dire que ça veut
dire que la culture a corrigé la chose
et que la violence est de plus en plus
mal vécu parce qu'on est de plus en plus
un toolérant à la violence et à
l'agressivité c'est en cela que je suis
plus optimiste que vous ouais Jean-Louis
Chassin on penser que cette violence
était là hier elle est aujourd'hui et
que la vérité freudienne est
intemporelle et permanente alors déjà
parler de pessimisme ou d'optimisme
c'est très très à l'heure du temps ENF
hein c'est-à-dire effectivement il
s'agit de mettre un peu d'affect alors
que le les textes de Freud et puis de
des continuateurs de Freud sont plutôt
des textes qui essaient d'avoir un
raisonnement hein plus que des troubles
de l'humeur pour reprendre les les les
choses d'aujourd'hui et je trouve que
c'est intéressant de donc moi je
parlerai pas de pessimisme ou
d'optimisme hein j'essaie de lire Freud
et puis lac enfin d'une manière plus
plus logique hein que d'une d'une
manière où on met de l'humeur mais je
trouve que bon qu'est-ce quel qu'est-ce
quel est ce malaise et euh est-ce qu'il
est encore actuel Freud y va très
fortfin au début de son de son texte
hein je dire qu'il y a trois
euh trois occasions d'être mal hein
c'est-à-dire avec son corps avec le
monde extérieur et dans la relation à
l'autre et c'est effectivement ce
dernier point que Freud va étudier
puisque c'est l'autre chose que
j'aimerais dire c'est que Freud euh
n'est pas sociologue et il il a écrit un
texte qui est en je crois 1932 sur la
veltan shaung hein c'est-à-dire comme
quoi la psychanalyse n'est pas une
vision du monde hein et donc je pense
que cette vision du monde comme ça n'est
pas possible pour la psychanalyse on
sait d'ailleurs par rapport à la
question oui mais quand il quand il dit
que dès qu'il y a une multitude les gens
s'entretuent c'est quand même une vision
du monde non l'autre l'autre point c'est
aussi sa spécificité hein c'est et dans
ces textes il parle toujours et assez
souvent d'ailleurs d'une similitude
entre l'individuel et le collectif
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a toujours un
allerretour entre les deux hein c'est
c'est pas seulement parler de du
collectif hein mais le collectif c'est
aussi le sujet individuel on va rentrer
dans le détail hein
là-dessus votre point vue pierre de
sénarclance vous enseignez les sciences
politiques est-ce que vous pensez que
Freud est un éclaireur politique des
crises et il est dans tous les cas un
éclaireur politique et il rejoint disons
une tradition de la politique
internationale qui associe effectivement
l'humanité à à l'agression de ce point
de vue-là
Freud énonce des des des des postulats
qui sont assumés largement dans la
politique internationale mais Freud
établit un lien entre le processus
civilisateur et la limitation de
l'agressivité et il montre que cette
limite de ce processus civilisateur
entraîne un malaise et aujourd'hui nous
devons vivre avec un malaise qui est
différent de celui qu'il avait mis en
avant mais qui n'en reste pas moins un
malaise important face aux contraintes
de civilisation oui al et pour revenir à
ce qui a été dit sur disons l'immédiate
après-gerre ce qui a dominé cette après
guerre tout de même c'était un haut
degré
d'institutionnalisation de la politique
internationale pas seulement par les
organisation internationale mais aussi
par l'équilibre de la terreur n'est-ce
pas qui créait quand même quelque chose
qui était difficile de modifier dans cet
équilibre et la fin de l'histoire
c'était idée que ayant cette cette
confrontation de la guerre froide étant
terminée on allait pouvoir enfin
réaliser ensemble ce processus de
céisation Mill làdessus je je je sens
que je je dans cette émission je vais
désespérer ma voisine madame la ministre
parce que qui comme souvent quand nous
sommes dans des émissions communes vous
me désespz parce queoup c'est c'est le
moment de dire presque de corriger ce
que vous avez dit au début c'est le
moment de dire que non seulement quand
la multitude est là il y a il y a en
effet du meurtre dans l'air mais même
lorsqu'il y en a que deux il faut quand
même rappeler qu'après tout le début de
l'histoire tel que la Bible le raconte
il en aura pas dans cette émission non
certainement
pas lorsque l'histoire commence après
tout après Adam et ve c'est c'est les
deux frères qui s'entretu à B donc dès
qu'il y en a deux c'est quand même ça
que la psychanalyse met en avant qui
ve juste de vous interrom comment vous
expliquz dans ce cas-là que nonobstant
tous les progrès la civilisation humaine
dans les pays
démocratiques n'arrivve pas à venir à
bout de la pulsion d'agression que
certains considère comme une
décivilisation voire même comme un
ensauvagement je vais répondre à votre
question de façon très claire quelle est
la grande découverte de Freude la grande
découverte de Freud c'est que nous ne
voulons pas notre bien si si si nous
interrgeons tout un chacun chacun peut
avoir l'idée que ce qu'il souhaite c'est
finalement être heureux comme comme un
un coque en patte pas du tout diffreud
il y a quelque chose qui nous fait
travailler contre nous-mêmes c'est c'est
ça la pulsion de mort la pulsion de mort
c'est pas le fait de vouloir détruire
l'autre c'est d'abord une pulsion qui
travaille contre nous-même et donc cette
découverte notamment qu'il découvre dans
au-delà du principe du plaisir qu'il y a
quelque chose de plus fort que que la
recherche du plaisir la recherche du
bien-être la recherche de l'homéostase
l'homéostase c'est ça et ben nous au
contraire être humains nous voulons la
crise nous voulons pas seulement
l'agressivité la mort de l'autre nous
voulons quelque chose qui nous détruit
nous-même c'est en ce sens-là madame la
ministre qu'en effet nous sommes
fondamentalement je garde le terme de
pessimiste nous sommes fondamentalement
pessimistes parce qu'il y a quelque
chose qui nous fait travailler contre
nous-mêmes ouais laissezla parler
Juliette méadelle qu'est-ce que que que
la grande découverte de Freud soit soit
que nous ayons en nous-même une pulsion
de mort ou une pulsion d'autodestruction
qui cohabite avec le désir de vivre et
d'être heureux c'est une évidence mais
ce que je trouve plus intéressant dans
la question que vous posez c'est la
question du collectif et donc la
question est plus politiquement c'est
est-ce que collectivement nous en sommes
arrivés à un stade de développement de
notre société j'aime pas dire notre
civilisation mais de notre société au
moins qui est un stade d'autodestruction
et c'est ça à mon sens la grande
question qui est posée par la
rarefaction des ressources naturelles et
par un capitalisme qui devient fou et ce
qui à mon avis le le cœur et votre
émission et le sujet violance est encore
plus grande dans les pays
totalitaires il n'ont pas le capitalisme
comme substrat mais qui ont autre chose
et donc les pays totalitaires dont vous
parlez dont on entend de plus en plus la
voix aujourd'hui qui semble d'ailleurs
se ligué ensemble je parle de la Chine
de la Russie contre un autre modèle un
contre mododèle le nôtre qui est un
modèle certes capitaliste avec ses
dévoiements ces deux modèles là ça fait
un choc dont chacun d'entre eux cherche
à détruire l'autre et qui porte aussi en
lui-même sa propre destruction c'est ça
à mon avis le tournant que nous allons
vivre dans les années qui viennent et
c'est donc au moins une pulsion
individuelle d'autodestruction qui
évidemment vous l'avez très bien dit est
inhérente à l'homme que une forme de
pulsion collective et c'est ça qui est
très merci Juliette al Jean-Pierre leof
je voudrais que vous précisiez quelque
chose parce que le point de vue
analytique c'est qu'il y a une pulsion
d'autodestruction chez l'individu ça a
été souligné par Gérard Miller et
Jean-Louis Chassin mais est-ce
que y a une distinction qu'on peut faire
entre Freud et Aaron parce que Aaron dit
l'homme est raisonnable mais les hommes
le sont-il alors est-ce que c'est la
multitude qui vient aiguiser la pulsion
d'agression ou est-ce que cette pulsion
d'agression elle est originaire dans la
dans la personne moi je pense qu'elle
est originaire ça veut pas dire que la
multitude ne la croit pas ne la croit
pas quant à Aaron il y a une vision de
l'histoire qui reste tragique chez Aaron
c'està dire l'histoire est ouverte sur
des possibles y compris sur des
possibles totalitaires puisque c'est
quand même quelqu'un qui a lutté contre
le totalitarisme mais ce qui ce qui
s'agit à mon avis de comprendre je pense
c'est Steiner qui était un critique
littéraire qui disait nous avons appris
avec la guerre que finalement les
bibliothèques les œuvres d'art peuvent
coexister à cô à côté des camps de
concentration dans une civilisation une
société allemande qui avait créé des
musiques formidables des arts et
CER y a même un film qui montre que le
gardien d'Auschwitz ne se rendait pas
compte apparemment de ce qui se passait
dans le camp de concentration oui
apparemment ou oui avec une idéologie
d'enfermement on peut essayer de mettre
de côté mais je pense que donc les
premières je dirais me caer une question
plus générale y a-t-il une progression
dans la morale en morale est-ce qu'on
peut penser la progression morale comme
on pense le développement économi social
du bien-être je ne crois pas je crois
qu'il y a il y a effreux Dei moi pour
moi lapport de freute je suis pas
psychanalyste c'est ça c'est qu'il y a
quelque chose d'irréductible alors ça
veut pas dire qu'il faut pas essayer de
le combattre ça c'est trutre chose mais
il faut savoir qu'en essayant de le
combattre il y a toujours un reste il y
a toujours un prix à payer et que
précisément la civilisation il y aura
toujours une insatisfaction qui est liée
à ce point-là et je pense que au-delà
même de la psychanalyse c'est un
enseignement qui va au-delà qui on a
parlé de la dimension politique mais
même dans la dimension sociale et
aujourd'hui moi je vois par exemple ce
que j'appelle la si vous voulez la la
déglingue d'un mot un
peu familier c'est-à-dire c'est pas
simplement la dimension
économicsocial c'est aussi une
dstructuration que je paruxler presque
anthropologique c'estàdire quand vous
conjuguez le chômage de masse
c'està-dire l'absence de travail
l'absence d'épreuv du réel et de
sentiment d'utilité dans la société avec
les dstructurations familiales les
solidarité collective je pense qu'on a
affaire à des formes de dstructuration
nouvelles qui sont pas simplement la
pauvre é ancienne parce que la pauvreté
ancienne vous pouviez gagner peu
d'argent mais vous aviez une forme
d'estime de vous-même si vous voulez et
puis vous étiez insérés dans une
collectivité il y avait une morale
commune ce qui me frappe par exemple
dans certaines émeutes ou dans des
jeunes ce qu'on voit dans lesff on va
rentrer dans le détail de cette chose là
non mais juste un point c'est ça veut
dire que par exemple chez les policiers
les éducateurs ils disent mais on est
frappé par une chose il y a pas de
sentiment de culpabilité et précisément
chez fre le sentiment de stabilité est
liée au phénomène civilisationnel oui
pierre deénarin pas faire je veux pas me
faire l'avocat des anges mais j'aimerais
quand même rappeler que nous avons
atteint un très haut degré de
civilisation en particulier en Europe
nous avons harmonisé nos relations nous
avons pacifié nos relations sociales au
point que effectivement nous ne
comprenons plus les raisons de faire la
guerre alors évidemment cette
institutionnalisation elle n'est chacun
ne la vit pas de la même manière
certains se révolent contre cette
institutionnalisation contre ces normes
en particulier les populistes mais il
faut admettre que pour l'instant notre
socle civilisationnel tient bon et qu'il
est plus fort plus solide que beaucoup
de civilisations qui nous entourent
aujourd'hui et ça je crois qu'on doit
quand même en tenir compte ouis
Jean-Louis Chassin qu'est-ce que vous
êtes d'accord pour considérer
qu'aujourd'hui il y a un dég aujourd'hui
comme hier il y a un déglingage
anthropologique selon le terme de
Jean-Pierre legof alors c'est-à-dire que
il y a beaucoup de choses qui fichent le
camp je me pose oui mais lesquels enfin
je dire effectivement qu'est-ce qui
qu'est-ce qui a changé question est-ce
que la
déchristianisation est-ce que la
solitarisation des familles est-ce que
la pression des minorités est-ce que
tous ces éléments est-ce que le fait que
les inégalités
sociale demeure malgré le progrès social
est-ce que tout ça fait que ça contribue
à un déglingage anthropologique en
quelque sorte j'insiste à nouveau sur le
fait que
Freud
associe sa pratique privée c'est-à-dire
en tant que
psychanalyste c'est-à-dire travaille
théoriquement la question de
l'individuel de
l'individu avec cette notion a très bien
décrit Gérard Miller mais euh je suis
toujours pas d'accord avec le fait de
garder le mot pessimisme hein je dire
c'est un peu contradictoire d'ailleurs
enfin parce que vous évoqueiez très bien
ce qui est structural finalement hein et
alors je vais pas reprendre mais ça
serait intéressant qu'est-ce que c'est
que la pulsion de mort pourquoi à un
moment donné Freud il amène ça il
l'amène à la fois par ses par ses
analyses personnelles et puis c'est vrai
enfin par une une interrogation sur la
civilisation et il observe aussi la
montée du nazisme dans la ville où où il
travaillit la montée des intolérances
mais il a aussi une pratique
individuelle et je dire sans cesse il
associe l'individuel et le je veux pas
dire le sociologique parce que ça n'est
pas son ça n'est pas son rôle ça n'est
pas sa fonction hein mais ce que je veux
dire c'est que si c'est structural je
reviens sur la question de la
contradiction hein mais si c'est
structural oui enfin je dire
effectivement vous avez très bien dit
que et ça va complètement à l'inverse de
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui nous ne
sommes pas si bons que ça hein enfin
finalement voilà enfin il y a quelque
chose qui fait que au fond de nous-même
il y a quelque chose qui peut s'appeler
la pulsion de mort ou et c'est ce que
l'on peut voir aujourd'hui et qui va
donner si l'on peut dire les voix à la
pulsion de mort de d'agir et qui est la
haine hein et effectivement est-ce qu'il
y a un pessimisme à ça pour probablement
oui sans doute on peut regarder ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui hein alors quand
quand vous évoqueiez le le pourquoi et
les changement dans dans la revue
lacanienne que nous avons publié ces
deux dernières
années quels ont été les titre le marché
de l'identité parce que il faut nommer
un peu enfin ce qui change et ce qui est
problématique l'identité c'est quoi hein
et c'est important aujourd'hui cette
question là le marché de l'identité les
croyances
ça ça aussi c'est quelque chose de
fondamental qu'est-ce qu'il en est de la
des croyances aujourd'hui ça c'était le
deième numéro le troisième numéro qui
est sorti il y a quelques mois c'est n n
au pluriel hein et c'est là-dessus
qu'effectivement nous pouvons travailler
quels ont été les changements de cela
hein mais ce sont des comment dire ce
sont des thèmes qui lient à la fois
notre pratique et puis comme vous le
disiez enfin je dire qu'une moi je
dirais pas une vision du monde parce
parce que fre est opposé hein mais une
analyse une analyse de des civilisations
oui alors haine
identité ce qu'on constate aujourd'hui
dans les dictatures totalitaires état ou
groupe terroriste il y a également cette
pulsion autodestructrice on le voit au
Proche Orient notamment avec le Porom du
7 octobre opéré par le ramas on le voit
dans la guerre avec luukraine
à votre avis
euh cette
permanence de la pulsion
autodestructrice malgré la pulsion
civilisatrice si on peut dire comment
vous expliquez ça Juliette merdel mais
je je le prendrais dans un sens un peu
différent et je dirais pour quand même
essayer de garder une touche d'optimisme
que ce combat que mène le Hamas en
Israël ou même que même Poutine en
envahissant l'Ukraine est aussi un
combat qui est dirigé contre un autre
modèle civilisationnel en l'occurrence
le nôtre le nôtre qui comporte ses
propres pulsions d'autodestruction vise
quand même à une forme d'apaisement dans
les relations social je partage pas
l'idée que nous en serions au même stade
relationnel les uns avec les autres que
ce que nous avons vécu pour ne pas le en
1929 ou même après la deuxème guerre
mondiale je crois profondément qu'il y a
quand même un progrès aujourd'hui y
compris pensé par le politique dans les
les ne serait-ce que l'accompagnement
social il y a des ambitions aujourd'hui
qui sont donnés par les gouvernements en
Europe en général pas pas partout mais
prenons la France on est quand même dans
un modèle où aujourd'hui on s'intéresse
quand même au à par exemple aux victimes
c'est l'ancienne secrétaire d'État aide
aux victimes qui vous parle mais quand
François Hollande crée par exemple et
quand on met en place la politique
d'aide aux victimes qu'est-ce qu'on fait
et bien on dit tout individu doit avoir
accompagn
fr on a les attentats de l'yach et
exctement parce que parce que
précisément c'est des attentats qui sont
dirigés contre un autre modèle de
société le nôtre qui est un modèle qui
repose sur l'égalité la liberté la
fraternité sur la non agression sur la
non violence sur le recours par l'État à
la violence uniquement dans un cadre
légal sur l'intervention du juge sur un
hôpital qui soigne même quand on est en
situation irrégulière sur un droit au
logement donc tout ça alors évidemment
c'est loin d'être parfait mais tout ça
ça forge quoi ça forge quand même un
projet de société qui est infiniment
moins violent et moins contraignant du
point de vue et et qui a vocation à
brider les pulsions le nôtre ça forge
quand même les bases d'un modèle de
société qui à mon sens est bien plus
enviable que ce que nous pouvons trouver
dans un état
totalitaire je suis presque d'accord
avec vous pres je suis presque d'accord
avec vous et je vais si vous me le
permettez le permettez le formuler en
freudien c'est-àdire que ce qui est
lorsqu'on est freien acquis c'est
finalement la surprise ce ne soit pas
que des gens se retrouvant s'entretue la
surprise c'est de savoir pourquoi il ne
s'entretu pas donc d'une certaine façon
je je considère que nous ne sommes pas
moins sauvage que on l'était au
Moyen-Âge ou qu'on l'était sous
Jésus-Christ mais il y a quelque chose
qui a incroyable ement progresser qu'il
faut protéger comme la prunelle de nos
yeux c'est ce que lac appelle symbolique
qu'est-ce qui fait qu'on ne s'entretue
pas c'est que justement il y a entre
nous quelque chose qui s'échange donc
d'une certain façon l'homme ne progresse
pas mais les institutions dont il se
doent le protège et de ce point de vue
là je dirais que collectivement
effectivement les hommes se rendent
compte de ça et c'est pour ça c'est
extrêmement précieux de ne pas toucher
au signifiant que nous échangeons quand
je vois pour parler d'aujourd'hui comme
on parle d'un certain nombre d'êtres
humains à savoir les étrangers et pas
seulement d'ailleurs les migrants
clandestins quand je vois la façon dont
on en parle je me dis c'est du plus
grand danger parce que quand on commence
à parler d'êtres humains de cette
façon-là on met en danger l'ensemble de
la société c'est l'ensemble des éléments
symboliques qui me permet de vous
considérer comme mon semblable ou de
considérer celui qui n'a pas la même
couleur de peau que moi la même religion
comme mon semblable donc les hommes ne
progressent pas mais les institutions en
effet dont ils se dotent et qui sont
précieuses progresse et c'est vrai que
vous avez raison du coup de dire nous ne
sommes pas dans les mêmes systèmes que
dans les dictature et nous ne sommes pas
non plus comme on était au Moyen-Âge il
y a beaucoup de choses et c'est pour ça
qu'il faut faire très attention et c'est
en ce sens là que l'extrême droite pour
parler d'elle est extrêmement dangereuse
c'est qu'elle remet en question les
signifiants le symbolique qui nous
permet de coexister oui vous vouliez
réagir je vais vous donner la parole à
chacunierre leoui je voulais dire sur
les démocrati il s'agit évidemment pas
de confondre le totalitarisme et la
démocratie cela étant dit il y a des
aspects aussi à mon avis internees de
faiblesse interne aux démocraties et
notamment une forme de mésestime de soi
d'une certaine façon et une forme de
culpabilité qui peut se comprendre mais
qui peut devenir très malsine
c'est-à-dire en gros nos sociétés
seraient responsa quasiment de tous les
mots et grande une grande difficulté
vous donner la parole oui une grande
difficulté justement à admettre qu'on
puisse avoir des ennemis qui veulent
nous détruire et je pense qu'il y a une
pate d'estime de soi au sein même des
démocraties par rapport aux ressources
que constitue notre propre histoire
notamment les lère mais il y en a
d'autres et une grande difficulté à
assumer ça surtout qu'en face vous avez
des gens qui vous disent directement
nous la mort il y a pas de problème
Jean-Pierre est-ce que vous pouvez
préciser ce point est-ce que dans ce
déglingage que vous observez vous im
metettz la
déchristianisation la perte des valeurs
des lumières quelque chose que
l'Occident aurait oublié ce sont passé
oui ouiou mais il y a encore des
ressources hein je pense qu'il y a que
j'appelle des réserves d'humanité qui
sont là mais qui vont toujours combattre
quelque chose qui est assez IR
réductible et qui revient à chaque fois
et le problème c'est l'état des
ressources internes des démocraties
notamment européennes par rapport à leur
propre histoire et la façon dont elles
se pensent elles-même et du rôle que les
gens a joué dans l'histoire là je pense
qu' y a un point de faiblesse face à des
ennemis qui eux non'ont évidemment
totalitaires n'ont aucun problème
c'est-à-dire eux on est prêt à mourir on
ne craint pas la mort ça c'était le
discours des terroristes la différence
et pourquoi on va vous vaincre c'est
parce que vous vous aimez la vie c'est
quand même extraordinaire quand vous
écoutez un peu ces discours et donc je
pense qu'il y a une faiblesse interne à
reconnaître qu'on a des ennemis ça veut
dire il y a des gens qui veulent nous
détruire et qu'il faut combattre et ça
c'est pas simplement la non
violence nonolencean-louis Chassin oui
moi je je sur ce point je reviendrai sur
cette question de sur ce mot de
déglingage enfin justement par rapport à
ce que vous disiez enfin de la
déchristianisation je j'insistais tout à
l'heure sur la question des croyances
hein le c'est pas la même chose et non
mais je les sectes et les religions
c'est pas pareil ah oui mais qu'est-ce
qui qu'est-ce qu'il en est aujourd'hui
enfin je veux dire est-ce que justement
les les les les sectes ne prolifèrent
pas et de quelle religion s'agit-il
parce que le le déglinguage moi je
l'entends comme par exemple le le titre
de de du numéro de la revue c'est
qu'est-ce que vous croyez qu'est-ce que
vous croyez hein et donc c'est
effectivement la multiplication des
croyances de tout un chacun enfin
aujourd'hui on a pu le voir vous parliez
tout à l'heure enfin de la covid on a vu
effectivement je ve dire que les
sciences la politique était
quotidiennement et pratiquement remis en
question par le fait que chacun a sa
propre croyance concernant effectivement
cette pathologie et puis ça c'était
quand même quelque chose qui était un
petit peu délicat et difficile moi
j'étais très intéressé par ce par ce duo
scientifique politique hein et je
relisais donc euh Yersin Yersin qui qui
qui était un médecin qui a découvert le
bacile de la peste et qui à un moment
donné dit bon moi j'ai découvert ça
c'est très bien j'ai fait un vaccin j'ai
découvert les bactéries j'ai fait un
vaccin ok 2 ans plus tard rebelote a à
nouveau une peste on appelle hierersin
il dit attendez je suis désolé moi j'ai
j'ai découvert et le et la bactérie et
le vaccin aux politiques d'aller voir un
petit peu maintenant pourquoi il y a à
nouveau quelque chose qui revient hein
mais
sur le plan du citoyen cette question là
n'intéressait personne dire chacun avait
sa propre croyance je je reviens aussi
sur cette parce qu'il y a beaucoup de
choses sur cette question pourquoi
autodestruction ou pourquoi
autodestruction la pulsion de mort c'est
pas une autodestruction la pulsion de
mort c'est la pulsion de mort hein et
donc Freud a repris ça un peu à
sabinapil rein qui elle parlait de
destruction mais c'est pas la même chose
et c'est pas une autodestruction non
plus la pulsion de mort c'est quelque
chose chose qui vient dans un au-delà du
principe du plaisir hein que Lacan a pu
appeler la jouissance et qui est quelque
chose c'est une autre pulsion hein et
elle est pas forcément autodestructrice
au départ oui pierre de
sénarclass je crois qu'il y a un texte
de Freud qui est tout à fait remarquable
c'est celui qu'il écrit en 1915
lorsqu'il réfléchit sur l'effondrement
de ce que l'on peut appeler alors la
civilisation européenne et il met en
évidence l'extraordinaire fragilité de
nos civilisations et en particulier de
nos mécanismes institutionnels qui
visent à contenir ou à endiguer les
pulsions et dans ce texte on sent une
nostalgie d'un monde d'avant-guerre euh
qui s'est effondré et qui s'est effondré
aussi parce que pas seulement parce que
les individus voulaient réaliser leur
pulsion mais parce que les
institutions contenait une énorme
agressivité qui a été mobilisée par les
gouvernements mais ça nous renvoie aussi
au fait que autant de Freud les
contraintes sur moïque étaient quand
même beaucoup plus fortes que de nos
jours n'est-ce pas et aujourd'hui on vit
dans un monde où ces contraintes se sont
en partie évaporé nous n'avons plus de
contraintes religieuses en passant en en
noubliant pas que Freud pensait que la
religion chrétienne était une nvreuse de
contrainte de l'humanité mais enfin je
je passe là-dessus mais on a plus ces
croyances structurantes on a plus de
modèle d'autorité et on a on est dans
une société sans père une société où les
enfants sont élevé très longtemps sans
contrainte et cette absence de
contrainte suscite dans une société de
désir une société où on réalise nos
désirs et ces sociétés créent aussi
énormément de frustration et cette
frustration
à tout ce qui entrave les désirs
n'est-ce pas et on a aujourd'hui
beaucoup de peine à accepter des modèles
d'autorité des modèles hiérarchiques qui
nous permettrai d'assumer un idéal du
moin qui soit à peu près stable et
constant et ce qui la conséquence c'est
sont repli sur des groupes sur des
sectes sur des des petites organisations
qui ont de la peine à collaborer et à
faire communauté ensemble
[Musique]
alors on s'aperçoit que Freud à travers
cette citation et dans Malaise dans la
civilisation c'est très net Freud se
méfieré de l'idéologie
révolutionnaire comme de toutes les
idéologies d'ailleurs il a refusé de
prendre parti sur des causes politiques
que son ami Adler
proposé est-ce que sa méfiance vis-à-vis
des des idéologies qui ont pour finalité
la pulsion de de mort parfois camouflé
en bien de l'humanité est-ce qu'à votre
avis au regard des conflits sanglants
d'aujourd'hui qui ont pour marque
idéologique le communisme le fascisme
l'islamisme que samproun George sproun
l'écrivain considéré comme un
totalitarisme vert est-ce qu'il avait
raison d'avoir cette méfiance
idéologique Gérard Miller je vous
regarde pas avec une intention prononcée
mais j'aimerais avoir votre avis
là-dessus alors d'abord il faut préciser
pour ceux qui nous regardent que le
moins qu'on puisse dire c'est que Freud
n'était pas ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui
un homme de gauche alors il était encore
moins un révolutionnaire d'ailleurs il
s'intéressait très peu à la politique il
était surtout avec laacan était dans
cette même
position votre frère l'a dit dans une
émission ici votait je crois pour le
général de Gaulle euh non mais c'est
important que mis à part l'intérêt
prononcé qu'il avait pour la question
juive notamment pour les persécutions
évidemment contre les Juifs euh Freud
n'était pas un politique ce qui ne l'a
pas empêché d'écrire des textes
incroyablement justes politiquement
comme psychologie collective et analyse
du moi vous me permettrez d'ajouter à
votre liste je la j'y souscrirais si
vous ajoutiez aussi le colonialisme
l'impérialisme c'est-à-dire toutes
sortes d'au mes fait dire qui ne se
réduisent pas à à ce que la gauche a pu
produire de Terri j' accepte ses ajouts
voilà donc c'est c'est c'est sûr que euh
euh dans dans je citais psychologie
collective et analyse du moin qui est un
très beau texte de Freud qui est
notamment sur la montée du fascisme
finalement qui montre à quel point euh
euh la la on s'intéressait au collectif
à quel point ceux qui vivent
collectivement ont besoin d'un rapport
vertical hein que que que c'est c'est le
rapport au chef le rapport à une
idéologie bon de ce point de vue-là
permettez-moi de vous dire que le
psychanalyste que je suis ne croit pas
que la religion à travers l'histoire a
joué un grand rôle pacificateur même si
à certains moments c'était sans doute
utile donc le le vrai problème si vous
voulez je crois qu'on l'a évoqué un
moment à propos de la guerre en yoslavie
si vous me permettez de prendre cet
exemple qu'est-ce qui s'est passé dans
la guerre en Yougoslavie vous aviez un
certain nombre de peuples vous parlez de
99 avec le Kosovo avant même vous aviez
un certain nombre de peuples qui
cohabitaient tant bien que mal sous le
titisme bon et on avait fabriqué cette
entité bizarroïde j'en convient qu'on
appelle la youoslavie avec des gens qui
n'avaient pas la même langue on a créé
une langue d'ailleurs artificielle qu'on
a essayé d'imposer mais tant bien que
mal Croat bosniaque musulmans arrivé à
cohabiter parce qu'ils avaient des
éléments communs il s'échangeaient un
certain nombre de choses don notamment
la référence au pays et lorsque ça le
symbolique ça a cédé le frère a tué le
frère c'est qu'on a vu des gens moi je
me souviens professeur à l'université
d'avoir des étudiants bosniaques qui me
disaient lorsqu'on était jeune jamais on
se posait la question de savoir si le
voisin était oui mais parce que la
religion a émergé parce que tout d'un
coup effectivement le le peu de
symbolique qui avait et je ne vende pas
le titisme évidemment mais le peu de
symbolique qui y avait entre les gens et
qui permettaient de cohabiter ayant cédé
c'est le pire qui est remonté et
notamment les communautarismes les les
les groupes aineux les religieux donc
c'est c'est de ce point de vue-là si
vous voulez qu'il faut revenir à cette
idée essentielle trouvons les
signifiants qui nous permettent de
cohabiter les uns avec les autres et
chaque fois que ces signifiants sont mis
en jeu le pire est là le pire que ce
soit effectivement le stalinisme que ce
soit la dictature hyclairienne à chaque
fois c'est comment comment le dire mieux
sinon l'islamisme aujourd'hui au même
niveau ce que déjà sproun disait dans
les années 60 que c'était un
totalitarisme vert non écoutez il y a
aucun doute alors je ne sais pas s'il
faut le qualifier de totalitisme vert il
y a aucun doute que ce qu'on appelle
l'islamisme aujourd'hui est une
monstruosité absolue qui qui si vous
voulez c'est pour ça que je suis
toujours gêné d'ailleurs quand on dit
est-ce que c'est le fascisme ou pas le
fascisme tout ça s'inscrit grosso modo
dans la même eau et évidemment qu'on
voit bien effectivement vous évoquez le
le ramass et le le 7 octobre on voit
bien mais il y a beaucoup d'autres
exemples malheureusement on voit bien en
effet que ce sont des manifestations de
violence terroriste dictatoriale
faschisante de de la même eau après je
suis d'accord pour qu'on fasse des des
distinctions c'est la même chose oui sur
c'est justement ces idéologie meurtrière
oui je pense que c'est des idéologies
meurtrières par rapport à ce qui a été
dit moi je pense qu'on assiste quand
même en France à des forme de
désinstitutionnalisation je prendre un
exemple très concret le harcèlement
moral je me suis intéressé à cette
notion qui est apparue vers les années
90 c'està-dire le schéma qui domine
aujourd'hui dans le débat public c'est
la victime et je dirais un duel une
relation duelle entre une pure victime
et un purure Salou avec des phénomènes
de lapidation qui existe à travers les
médias et ça je pense que vous parliez
des démocraties et ce qui il y a une
victimologie qui à mon avis
est significative de cette des
institutionnalisation on prend le
travail par exemple antérieurement vous
avez des conflits du travail ces
conflits du travail étaient envisagés
sous une dimension collective vous étiez
à l'intérieur d'un collectif et c'était
pas simplement votre subjectivité quand
vous vous hetiez au petit chef c'était
pas simplement moi individu avec mon
élément particulier face à un pervers
c'était moi participant d'un collectif
qui était à ce moment-là le monde
ouvrier la classe ouvrière face à à
quelqu'un qui représentait d'une
certaine une façon le capitalisme là on
a tous ces c'est comme si les horipos
institutionnels j'en le mot horipo entre
guillemets avaient sauté et à ce
moment-là vous avez ces affectes et ces
rencontres de subjectivité à
subjectivité qui à mon avis son autement
problématique je pense sans résumer
évidemment l'état des démocraties à cela
que c'est une des faiblesses internes de
la démocratie et quand les politique
encourage cette dimension là ils ne
savent pas ce qu'ils font à mon avis oui
alors moi je pardonnezm moi je partage
pas du tout ce que vous dites parce que
non non pas que je considère que faire
du particulier le représentant de
l'universel soit forcément une solution
mais je pense au contraire que ce que
nous avons vécu prenons par exemple
Mitou puisque c'est l'exemple plus
simple je vais pas vous parler des
victimes d'attentat mais je vais vous
parler de Mitou c'est quand même
aussi dans la société de communication
que nous avons aujourd'hui une manière
d'attirer davantage l'attention du grand
public sur sur une histoire qui raconte
un conflit de pouvoir l'hypothèse de la
jeune pupille d'un parrain qui abuse
d'elle sexuellement ou du patron par
exemple George Tron qui abuse de son
employé sur le plan sexuel c'est juste
un rapport de pouvoir qui s'exerce en
l'écrasante défveur de la victime donc
quand sur le plan effectivement
médiatique ou cinématographique ou même
sur le plan du récit on attire
l'attention sur un cas particulier ça
n'est jamais que en fait la mise en
mouvement d'un conflit institutionnel
l'institutionnel écrasant étant le
patron l'homme blanc de plus de 60 ans
contre oui mais je vais vous dire c'est
une réalité quantitative c'est-à-dire
que quand la démocratie aujourd'hui
s'enrichit de la défense des victimes
c'est juste le rétablissement d'une
injustice qui a qui perdure depuis la
nuit des temps et donc je ne considère
absolument pas et c'est une logique que
l'on peut par ailleurs appliquer au
droit du travail car le cas du
harcèlement moral au travail est
exactement le mêmeou c'est des
situations extrêmement difficile à
qualifier sur le plan judiciaire et
juridique car la preuve des faits commis
et de l'absence de consentement dans le
cas par exemple du harcèlement sexuel au
travail est très difficile à rapporter
donc 99 % des victimes de PL de de de
viol au travail neevenons à Freud si
vous voulez bien et donc revenons à
Freud la question institutionnelle
dire que ça n'entrave pas le bon
fonctionnement de la démocratie oui
juste un mot là-dessus vous êtes en
désaccord mais pourquoi pas on a le
droit ça veut pas dire qu'il y a pas des
victimes qui a des droits qu'elles
doivent porter ploi ça fait réresser la
démocratie que défend les victimes non
non non non euh ce que jeux dire par là
c'est très différent de la psychanalyse
parce que la psychanalyse dans le
rapport entre le pervers et la victime
suppose des mécanismes inconscients dans
lesquels les deux participent et ça
c'est complètement effacé au profit d'un
comportementaliste où on repère les bons
et les mauvais comportements encore une
fois ça veut pas dire qu'il y a pas de
victime mais je veux dire le schéma
comportementaliste entre le pur pervers
et sa victime et quelque chose qui a
pour le coup met en question un des un
des aspects de la psychanalyse qui me
paraît essentiel c'est qu'il y a une
autre scène par rapport à cette cette
scène manifeste et cette scène là est
plus compliquée c'est tout à partir de
là il y a la loi il y a la voulez on a
beaucoup de question je suis d'accord
avec vous sur le fait que la
parfois la psychanalyse la victime n'est
pas complètement aussi victime vous
entendu on vous a entendu je vais vous
donner parole j'aimis revenir sur
quelque chose qui devrait quand même
nous
préoccuper c'est ce problème de la notre
difficulté à résister aux frustrations
lorsqu'on a aujourd'hui un homme
politique qui a été Président des
États-Unis et qui risque de le redevenir
et qui permis dans sa carrière politique
de dire tout et n'importe quoi d'avoir
affirmé qu'il pouvait descendre dans la
5e avenue de tuer quelqu'un et d'être
néanmoins réélu d'avoir humilié ses
oppos et je parle de Donald Trump mais
c'est ant je parle pas de Donald Trump
je parle d'une foule de gens qui se sont
suffisamment identifiés à ce voyou pour
accepter de voter pour lui je crois que
c'est un grand problème d'expliquer
pourquoi aujourd'hui tant de gens
s'identifient à un personnage de cette
nature parce que l'élection est un choix
identitaire et dans la question de de
des États-Unis dans la question du
populisme en Europe on s'aperçoit que
les les les idées qui gouvernent les
populistes sont très fragiles il y a pas
d'idéologie par contre il y a des
comportements il y a des comportements
iconoclastes il y a des comportements de
voyou il y a des comportements et des
idées qui sont très incohérentes mais
qui visent en quelque sorte à détruire
les procédures et les institutions
pourquoi est-ce qu'on s'identifie à ces
gens ça c'est la grande question qui
nous intéresse Jean-Louis Chassin je
voudrais sur ce point avoir votre
avis j'ai lu
Freud j'ai même publié un livre
là-dessus comment vous expliquer que
Freud en 36 37 38 il
appréhendait la violence du nazisme il
en a même été victime mais il pensait il
pensait que les institutions tiendraient
et qu'on n'arriverait pas à cette
catastrophe est-ce que de sa part à
votre avis c'était de la naïveté et que
tout allait être emporté ou est-ce que
il pensait que la civilisation des
Lumières à laquelle il appartenait
ferait digue face à cette que vous le
vouliez ou pas cette pulsion
exterminatrice qui a contribué à la
choix mais justement enfin pendant ces
années que vous évoquez il a écrit ses
textes dit anthropologie de la
psychanalyse hein et donc effectivement
il il avait cette il avait cette
inquiétude de savoir ce qui se passé
dans les civilisations après 1920 après
avoir découvert et posé la question
question de la pulsion de mort oui mais
sa santé était en jeu dans les années 30
il a été sauvé
miraculeusement grâce à un concours
diplomatique international qui mêle
l'ambassadeur des États-Unis la
princesse Bonaparte et cetera mais je
crois que Y a ouais il y a cette
relation de alors bien sûr ça concerne
pas essentiellement les civilisations
mais il y a cette relation assez modéré
de Freud à la politiquein et il était
assez prudent par rapport à ça autant il
a pu être osé dans ses descriptions des
civilisations et puis il a eu des appuis
politiques aussi il y a eu un moment où
il a été expert contre un de ses amis
après la guerre et o où il a eu des
appuis politiques qui étaient très très
importants mais on lui demandait
quelqu'un comme isterman par exemple lui
a demandé et vous parce qu'on insistait
sur ça enfin je ve dire c'est une
insistance sur sa position qu'êtes-vous
politiquement réponse de Freud
politiquement je ne suis rien bon je
dire mais les textes sont politiques
alors les textes sont politiques mais on
lui demandait oui oui mais
attendez attendez on lui demandait en
insistant oui mais quand même quelle est
votre couleur hein ni rouge ni blanc
quelle est votre couleur réponse de
Freud réponse d'analyste réponse de
Freud je suis couleur cher C H a i r
c'est tout à fait surprenant
c'est-à-dire couleur de l'homme et pas
de la peau hein mais aussi ajoutait-il
sans pour autant aller à fond du côté
d'un humanisme voilà donc voilà par
rapport à la question de la politique le
seul engagement qu'il a pu avoir c'était
par rapport à quelque chose qui ne s'est
pas fait et qui était un ordre
international de la culture et de
l'éthique et il demandait à ce que ça
soit à la Société des Nations hein et ça
ne s'est pas fait je voudrais quand même
revenir sur cette question là que vous
évoqueiez de Donald
Trump c'est une interrogation mais
justement je dire ce que ce qu'a dit
Gérard Miller et ce que c'est pourquoi
moi je plaide aussi en tant
qu'analyste moi ça ne me surprend pas du
tout qu'on puisse voter pour un homme
comme ça je dire que l'homme n'est pas
seulement bon et je dirais même que que
Trump soit accusé et qu'il se dépende et
qu'il se batte pour ça ça peut au
contraire augmenter son son charisme si
on peut dire je vais vous faire réagir
sur une dernière question qui concerne
la
la France a connu beaucoup de
révolutions ou d'épisodes
révolutionnaires
1848 la commune mai 68 les gilets jaunes
au regard de ce qu'il en est sorti
est-ce qu'à votre avis on pouvait éviter
les débordements violents est-ce qu'il
est possible de s'opposer à une fatalité
révolutionnaire freud disait il n'y a
pas de révolutionnaire qu'un autre plus
radical ne supplante autrement dit et
plus plus trivialement chasser le
naturel c'est-à-dire ces pulsion
psychique primitive revient au Galot
est-ce que vous pensez que on revient à
la question du début est-ce qu'il y a
cette fatalité révolutionnaire engendre
toujours des violences
ouut faut voir ce qu'on entend par
révolution c'estàdire si on entend par
ution une rupture radicale parce que
c'était quand même ça qui était en
question on peut dire qu'à partir de là
il y a une logique qui est enclenchée
entre 99 et 93 je pense que c'est pas
tout à fait la même chose mais il y a
déjà des germes en 89 qui vont jusqu'à
93 alors il y a deux lecture poss
possible où ces deux moments différents
de la révolution on pense que déjà il y
avait des germes des 89 mais il est
clair que la notion de révolution en ce
qu'elle implique une rupture radicale et
qui a été souvent accompagnée de la
fabrication d'un homme nouveau ça allait
un peu de paire si vous voulez et bien
oui effectivement si vous raisonnez dans
ce cadre-là oui et avec un phénomène où
les révolutionnaires finissent par je
veux dire s'autodévorer entre eux
c'est-à-dire qu'il eux-mêmes se se
liquident entre eux si vous voulez donc
il y a il y a ce mécanisme une fois
enclenché qui peut aller très loin en ce
sens-là oui euh je dirais oui par
rapport à votre question oui sur cette
fatalité c'est c'est c'est drôle que que
vous alignnez ces mouvements glorieux de
l'histoire française de la Révolution
9 que je conteste pasérard non mais vous
les alignez avec le terme de fatalité
moi je je mettrai ça du côté de la
chance c'estd ces moments-là qui ne se
tourn terminent pas tous très bien et
notamment pour les révolutionnaires
eux-mêmes ces moments-là sont on
contraire des moments où quelque chose
de l'humain va du côté de l'idéal va
plutôt du côté la question qui vous est
posée gérardire comme aux autres c'était
il n'y a pas de révolutionnaire qu'un
autre plus Radic ne supplante vous êtes
d'accord avec cette phras là ça c'est si
vous voulez pourquoi aujourd'hui
l'ancien gauchiste que je suis considère
que la révolution doit être citoyenne et
plus violente alors que lorsque j'étais
jeune je pensais que la violence on va
dire ça comme ça était accoucheuse de
l'histoire c'est justement parce qu'on
s'est aperçu quand même à un moment
donné que la violence révolutionnaire
jouait non seulement contre les méchants
mais aussi contre les supposés gentils
qu'elle se retournait en effet donc
c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui je
n'inviterai personne y compris les
gilets jaunes que j'ai soutenu a envoyé
un pavé ce que dans ma jeunesse j'ai eu
l'occasion de faire donc là où vous avez
raison c'est qu'en effet il est temps
pour ceux qui comme moi veulent changer
le monde de comprendre que ce n'est pas
par la violence révolutionnaire qu'on y
arrivera mais qu'est-ce qui retient
votre bras aujourd'hui d'envoyer un pavé
c'est ce qui ce qui retient outre outre
l'âge et et et la responsabilité d'un
certain nombre d'enfants et
petits-enfants c'est le fait que j'ai
quand même compris à un moment donné
vous allez me dire c'est mieux vaut tard
que jamais que la violence n'était pas
accoucheuse du meilleur quand en effet
ce que ce que ce que l'histoire des
révolutionnaires montre c'est à quel
point la violence révolutionnaire est
inévitablement détourner de ses
objectifs on va dire et de ses
idéaux vous répondre à la question que
vous avez posé sur Freud et les
révolutionnaires qui sont toujours
dépassé par de nouveaux révolutionnaires
c'est qu'il imaginait que le
révolutionnaire était une lutte contre
le père que ça s'institutionnalisait et
qu'il y avait des enfants qui allaient
ensuite détruire cette
institutionnalisation issue du monde
révolutionnaire j'ajouterais que discter
de la problématique française il faut la
comparer à ce qui s'est passé ailleurs
notamment les pays d'origine protestante
qui n'ont pas du tout eu ce même rapport
à la violence et à la terreur oui pour
vous Jean-Louis Chassin ou Mo je
révolution engendre révolution
radicalité engendre
radicalité sur ce pointl parce que c'est
notre point de conclusion j'aurais pas
répondre à votre question oui mais c'est
le point de la conclusion je reviendrai
à à Freud et notamment vous parliez tout
à l'heure enfin de de la Russie dans ce
texte sur la vision du monde fre
repartle un peu comme ça il reparle de
la révolution en Russie et il dit c'est
pas mal il y a quelque chose qui s'est
fait il y a un événement hein et puis à
un moment donné il dit on va voir oui
mais il a quand même condamné dans le
texte très clairement Juliette madel je
crois que l'enjeu ça n'est pas pour
l'avenir de la France la révolution mais
au contraire notre capacité à être
radicau et peut-être violent dans la
réponse à apportter aux assauts des
régimes totalitaire de l'extérieur mais
également des poussées de l'extrême
droite et donc il faut que nous soyons
radicaux pour préserver la libert
sincèrement sincèrement jette madelle
l'antisémitisme aujourd'hui est de
nature de l'extrême droite ou de
l'extrême gauche non mais non mais
répondez-moi là-dessus les deux mon
général voulez que je vous dise je ne
crois pas du tout que je que Le Pen et
que la famille leupen ou que le
rassemblement national protègera
davantage les Juifs mais personne ne
vous a posé cette questionl je les
renvoie dos à dos et je crois
qu'aujourd'hui toute forme d'idéologie
extrémiste porté par l'un ou l'autre des
camps est à proscrire et qu'il faut donc
être radicaux pour préserver la liberté
l'égalité et la fraternité et radicaux
ça veut peut-être dire que la faiblesse
des démocraties pour rebondir sur ce que
vous disiez c'est de ne pas croire assez
en leur propre force et en leur propre
modèle de liberté et d'égalité et de
fraternité je voudrais vous présenter
une brève bibliographie alors pour ceux
que Freud intéresse les œuvres complètes
ont paru au presse universitaire de
France donc vous pouvez lire tout ce que
Freud a écrit Jean-Pierre Legoff vous
avez publié mes années fol en un mot
vous regrettez ces années folles
c'est-à-dire quand vous étiez un
révolutionnaire vous bifez ça d'un trait
à la fin en disant j'étais naïf queou
non non non non je pense que ce que j'ai
ce que j'ai découvert en retravaillant
les textes c'est l'articulation entre un
certaine forme d'idéologie avec des
affectes et des passions et compris
adolessente voilà c'est ça c'est pas
simplement une histoire intellectualiste
simplement c'est pas simplement un
rapport au texte
in ça met en jeu des passions y compris
des passions problématiques si vous
voulez c'est ça donc vous comprenez
aussi que les gens veulent rester dans
cette durée adolescente euh ben je pense
que c'est arrêt sur image il y a un
moment l'épreuve du réel finit quand
même par vous rattraper enfin j'espère
voilà pierre de sénarclin vous avez
publié un livre directement sur nos
question nation et nationalisme aux
éditions des Sciences Humaines vous en
préparz à nouveau vous pensez que le
nationalisme est de tous les temps les
nationalismes les nationalismes je pense
qu'ils s'estompent mais ils prennent
d'autres forme lorsque l'on dit que la
droite populiste et nationaliste je suis
pas tellement sûr qu'elle l' dans la
mesure où elle a gardé du nationalisme
la haine des étrangers la xénophobie et
toutes sortes de choses de ce genre-là
mais elle collabore volontiers avec des
régimes étrangers pour avancer sa propre
cause donc l'idée nationale c'est un peu
estompé dans cet univers là
et l'évanescence de l'idée nationale
c'était aussi l'évanescence d'un lien
communautaire de solidarité qu'on a de
la peine à recréer aujourd'hui merci
vous préparez quelque chose Gérard mer
écoutez je je je prépare un nouveau film
qui n'est pas si éloigné de toute notre
discussion qui s'appelle comment
pouvait-on être maoïste en France sur un
mouvement que j'ai bien connu la Gauche
Prolétarienne qui explique cette ce qui
semble aujourd'hui une aberration que
des atres qui n'étaient pas complètement
cons comme nous ont pu être maoistes et
bien j'essaie de l'expliquer Juliette
madel un livre que vous préparé ou un
livre à une un livre fait qui s'appelle
un impérieux besoin d'agir où je
consacre deux chapitres à la question de
la nation et de la gauche car je crois
profondément au projet de la nation
d'Ernest Renan qui n'est pas du tout la
nation du mauvais nationalisme mais qui
est celui qui propose un récit collectif
d'intégration de liberté et c'est
précisément je crois l'un des combats
qu'il faut que nous je vous remercie
madame merci messieurs d'avoir participé
à cette émission je remercie l'équipe de
LCP avant de nous quitter je vous
soumets cette citation de Freud les
passions pulsionnelles sont plus fortes
que les intérêts
[Musique]
rationnels